if elections are supposed to be all
about the economy this was the day the
election really began both the
Conservatives and labor laying out
dramatic changes in their plans for
public spending and borrowing those
plans could radically change the way
this country looks labour pledged to
spend four hundred billion pounds in
total 250 of that on regional funds for
green infrastructure and energy and 150
billion pounds social transformation
fund through upgrading schools hospitals
and council houses over five years it
would increase investment by 55 billion
pounds a year more than doubling the
current total to do that John McDonald
is overhauling the party's fiscal rules
out goes his rule to reduce the national
debt to be replaced by a measure which
includes the value of nationalized
companies but it's not just labour Sajid
Javid has also committed to a spending
spree throwing out all his old borrowing
rules and replacing them with new ones
that could allow him to borrow up to 20
billion pounds more every year he Zacks
George Osborne and Philip Hammond
central rule at 2% of GDP limit on
borrowing and believe it or not replaced
it with pretty much the same one laborer
proposing of balanced budget and the
rule reducing the national debt is
replaced by a new rule limiting
government investment to 3 percent of
GDP around 60 billion pounds the big
question what will it actually mean for
government spending we've certainly had
quite different announcements from the
two parties today the level of
investment spending announced by the
Labour Party is very significantly more
than the additional spending announced
by by the Conservatives even though that
the conservative increase is very big
indeed by recent historical stands would
take investment spending back to its
highest level since the end of the 1970s
though other institutions here in the
City of London might have something to
say about that it saw everything we've
heard from the main political policies
today suggest not just that the era of
austerity is over but that a new era of
high spending high borrowing is about to
begin and the main thing holding them
back won't necessarily be those fiscal
rules but actually this place
if white all starts splurging it's up to
the Bank of England to decide whether to
put its foot on the brake and to raise
interest rates the bank's governor
underlining they are watching the
decisions in the spending round last
last month adds just under half a
percent to the level of GDP over the
forecast so you know that's a set of
decisions actual decisions that you will
have a notable affect on the forecast
and following the election there will be
a budget at some point and then we would
take that into account so we may not
know much about the precise economic
plans of either party but the big
picture is becoming clearer it's no
longer about fixing the roof when the
sun's shining whoever wins Parliament
looks set to kick-start the biggest
public investment boom since the 1970s
at Conway Sky News